we're told that a weather balloon
containing 1.85 times 10 to the third
liters of helium gas at 23 degrees
celsius and 765 torr
is launched into the atmosphere
the balloon travels for two hours before
bursting at an altitude of 32 kilometers
where the temperature is negative 44
degrees celsius and the pressure is 6.51
torr
what is the volume of the balloon just
before
it bursts
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right
so you might already have an intuitive
sense that this has something to do with
the ideal gas law because they're giving
us a bunch of pressures volumes and
temperatures and the ideal gas law deals
with that it tells us that pressure
times volume is equal to the number of
moles
times the ideal gas constant times
temperature
now what's different about this example
is that they aren't just giving us
several of these variables and asking us
to solve one of them they're talking
about these variables changing and how
that might affect other variables
and so one way to think about it is if
we divide both sides by t you get pv
over t is equal to nr and in this
example as this balloon goes to higher
and higher altitudes the number of moles
does not change and the ideal gas
constant does not change so one way to
think about it is that pv over t has to
be constant so our volume and our
temperature could change but because
this whole expression on the left has to
be constant that could then determine
our pressure or another way to think
about it you could say your starting
pressure times your starting volume over
your starting temperature is going to be
equal to the number of moles times the
ideal gas constant which also needs to
be equal to your pressure right before
it bursts times the volume right before
it bursts
divided by the temperature right before
it bursts or you could just say that p1
times v1 over t1 is equal to p2 times v2
over t2
and so what are these different
variables
well let's first think about p1
so pressure at time 1 is what it's 765
torr 765
torr and what's p2 that's the pressure
just before it burst and they tell us
it's 6.51 torr much lower pressure which
makes intuitive sense we're at a higher
altitude
6.51
torr now what is
v1
well they tell us that right over there
that is 1.85
times 10 to the third liters now what is
v2
well that's what they want us to figure
out what is the volume of the balloon
just before it bursts so i'll put a
little question mark there and then last
but not least what is t1
well they tell us the starting
temperature is at 23 degrees celsius but
you have to think on more of an absolute
scale and deal with temperatures in
terms of kelvin so to convert 23 degrees
celsius into kelvin you have to add 273.
so this is going to be 296
kelvin and then what is t2
well t2 is negative 44 degrees celsius
if we add 273 to that let's see that's
going to be if we subtract it's going to
be in my head 229
kelvin
and so we have everything we need in
order to solve for v2 in fact we could
solve for v2 before we even put in these
numbers if we multiply
both sides of this equation times t2
over p2 and the reason why i'm
multiplying it times this is so that
this cancels with this this cancels with
that so i have just v2 on the right hand
side of course i have to do that on both
sides t2
over p2 i am going to get and i'll now
color code it i'm going to get that t2
times
p1
times v1
over
p2
times t1
t
1
is equal to
v 2
v 2. so we just have to calculate this
right now let me give myself a little
bit more
real estate with which to do it and so
we could write that v2 is equal to t2
which is
229 kelvin times p1
which is
765
torr
times v1
which is 1.85
times 10 to the third liters
all of that
over
p2
which is 6.51
torr
times t1 which is 296
kelvin and we can confirm that the units
work out tor cancels with tor kelvin
cancels with kelvin so we're just going
to have a bunch of numbers a calculation
and our the units we're left with is
liters which is good because that is
what we care about when we care about
volume so this is going to be equal to
229
times 765
times 1.85
times
10 to the third
divided by 6.51
divided by 296 is equal to this business
right over here let's see we have three
significant digits here three
significant digits here three here three
here and three there so our answer is
going to have three significant figures
so it's going to be if we round it's
going to be 168 000 and so we could just
write that as 168 000 liters or if we
want to write that in scientific
notation we could write that as 1.68
times 10 to the 1 2 three four five
so let me write it that way so this is
going to be equal to 1.68
times 10 to the fifth
liters and i always like to do a nice
intuition check does that make sense so
our starting volume was
1850 liters and then our volume got a
lot larger because we're going to a much
higher altitude and that does make
intuitive sense to me